job try to save as many people as we can  sometimes that doesn't mean everybody  but you don't give up  New York  Washington DC  sokovia  okay that's enough captain people are  afraid  that's why I'm here  we need to put a check whatever form  that takes I'm good I'm sorry Tony if I  see a situation pointed South I can't  ignore it sometimes I wish I could  sometimes I want to punch you in your  perfect teeth I know we're not perfect  but the safest hands are still our own  I was wrong about you the whole world  was wrong about you they're coming for  you I'm not the one that needs to watch  their back this doesn't have to end in a  fight Tony  you just started a war  stay down final warning I could do this  all day  all right I've run out of patience  underoos  hey everyone  you